in Maryland the man accused of the
cold-blooded murder of five people at
the Annapolis Capitol Gazette had a
years-long grudge against the newspaper
in 2013 police were notified about
threatening tweets sent by Jared Ramos
towards the paper but they determined he
was not a threat Ramos is charged with
the murder in the deaths of Gerald
Fishman wendy winters John McNamara Rob
hyacinth and Rebecca Smith Paula Reid is
in Annapolis with the very latest Paula
good morning good morning police say the
suspect is still not cooperating but a
search of his apartment has revealed new
details about exactly how he planned
this attack we're also learning new
details about the investigation five
years ago when he first made threats
against the newspaper video shows the
moments after police took Jared Ramos
into custody
they say the 38 year old was hiding
under a desk in the Capitol Gazette
newsroom where he allegedly opened fire
on newspaper employees killing five and
wounding two more there were two
entrances to the offices in which this
attack occurred the rear door was
barricaded
mr. Ramos then as I told the judge
entered into the front door and worked
his way through the office where he
would shooting victims as he walked
through the office on Friday Ramos said
nothing as a judge ordered him to be
held without bond Thursday's shooting
appears to be the end of a long
simmering grudge Ramos held against the
paper according to court documents in
2012 Ramos filed an unsuccessful
defamation lawsuit against the paper and
a columnist who wrote an article about
allegations he harassed and threatened a
former high school classmate as the case
moved through the Maryland courts Ramos
wrote on Twitter that he was suing half
the county and making corpses of corrupt
careers and corporate entities in 2013
an Arundel Police Department
investigated online threats Ramos made
against the Capitol Gazette the
investigating officer noted in the
police report that he did not believe
Ramos was a threat to employees at the
paper ultimately the paper decided not
to press charges because it would be
like putting a stick in a beehive
attorney Brendan McCarthy represented
another woman who accused Ramos of
stalking her McCarthy tells CBS the
moment he heard about the shooting he
knew it was Ramos it was inevitable that
he was going to do something violent the
only question was who would he get first
president Trump who is called
journalists enemies of the American
people for marked on the shooting
journalists like all Americans should be
free from the fear of being violently
attacked while doing their job without
journalism there is no history on Friday
hundreds attended vigils across
Annapolis to remember the victims among
them winters dimer the daughter of the
Capitol slain special projects editor
wendy winters this is far too soon to
lose my mother he was a fantastic woman
a great mother and an amazing reporter
and
she was doing her job she was doing what
she loved to do this here this is
today's copy of the Capitol Gazette
newspaper and while as you would expect
the first few pages cover this tragedy
the rest of the paper is everything you
would expect from any local newspaper on
a Saturday stories about sports homes
for sale and even a new pastor at a
local church Dana
such strength in getting that paper out
in both the following days Paula Reed in
Annapolis thank you